welcome to another thankful Thursday I
believe that you can't do this alone as
an entrepreneur and there are people in
your business in your life who's who
helped you who believe when you who
support you so it it's worth it to take
a few minutes out of your day just to
say thank you so today i want to thank
Tim Schmoyer Tim runs an awesome youtube
channel called video creators and I
stumbled onto him not too long ago and
he's got so much great value on his
channel if you are trying to start a
launch grow a YouTube channel he's one
of the best guys online to follow I
watch every single video that comes out
and I was fortunate enough to be in one
of his videos giving my advice for
YouTube entrepreneurs as well so Tim I
just want to say thank you so much for
all the value you provide I love what
you're doing and I also reached out to a
few of the loyal Video Creator
subscribers and they had a few words to
say as well thank you so much Tim you've
really helped me a lot in a lot of other
youtubers you're a great asset to
YouTube you've really improved a lot of
our channels and we really appreciate
your tips and tricks and all your
knowledge so I thank you very much Tim
hi Tim I just want to thank you so much
for all of the video help you've given
me I get so many people messaging me
thanking me for my videos they wouldn't
have my videos if it wasn't for you you
have helped me find so many more
subscribers and able to reach out to
more people who love my videos so thank
you Tim I appreciate everything you've
done for us hey Tim all the way from
Trinidad and Tobago I just want to say
thank you so much for all the help you
have given to me at video creators by
surprise hey Tim what's going on to Evan
contacted me asking me that he wanted to
make a video saying basically how
awesome you are basically to give you a
big thank you big thank you for
everything that you do for this YouTube
community and I want to let you know
that how much I appreciate you all the
the training you give
all of the materials that you have I
just your friendship everything is just
so awesome and I don't think that I
would be as successful as I am with You
Tube without having found you and
applying some of your tactics and
whatnot and I think it's really awesome
that we've just become such great
friends over the years that we've we've
known each other so I chose that this
community really does work the fact that
people are making these types of
connections and we're we're changing
lives by making videos so I just wanted
to say thank you and thank you to Evan
for letting me be a part of this hi Tim
this is on him sad at the video spot net
and the whole hem staff family and we
wanted to say thank you so much for all
that you do to help young creators and
YouTube creators grow and become
profitable and everything that we eat
all the money that we make comes from
our video marketing business Tim and
you've been a leader in helping me
become a professional so it's no joke
when we say thank you for all the time
you put in the energy you put in thanks
so much Sarah would say by height m it's
Emily from bite size vegan and I wanted
to take a quick moment to thank you so
much for everything that you do you are
such an invaluable member of the YouTube
community and you give so much so freely
to so many people you've certainly made
a huge impact on my life in my channel
and I'm incredibly grateful for your
guidance I know that people have told
you this before but you could sell all
of your products and services for so
much money but you choose not to because
your priority is helping people change
lives by spreading their message and I
want you to know that you are doing just
that any impact that I or any of your
viewers make on our own audiences is
your impact as well so thank you Tim for
all that you do and who you are you are
a genuine person with a huge heart and
you are appreciated Tim's got here from
nerdsync just wanted to say thank you so
much for all of the hard work and effort
that you put into video creators it has
been immeasurably helpful this year for
our channel helping us grow and reach
more people and as you say change live
so thank you so much and I look forward
to what 2015 brings hey Tim one of the
main reasons I like video creators is
that you
able to gather up all of this
information and present it in a really
concise format that I find useful on
just about every single video but I
think the main reason I like video
creators is that you really practice
what you preach and you really have
created a community around your channel
and that's really to be committed so
thanks for all the hard work you do
thanks for all the work you've done this
year and I'm looking forward to next
year ola Tim Tony what the old nerd
reviews channel here I just want to say
thank you so much for all the hard work
you put into all your videos throughout
the years I've been watching you the
integrity the passion the self-sacrifice
both behind the camera and in front of
the camera you just absolutely make my
day whenever videos released so anyway
thanks a lot I so appreciate it you
become a huge part of my youtube arsenal
take care and have a freaking awesome
day see ya hey Tim Travis year and I've
been on YouTube for seven years and I
thought I knew everything but you've
shown me a lot and you continue to do so
and I really appreciate your
down-to-earth humble style so Tim I just
want to say thank you so much big
special thank you video for you Tim
Schmoyer because your channel is great
and I want to say thank you never stop
making these videos I also want to say
thank you to Evan for the opportunity
and because his channel is great as well
this is lavelle o gentle yes i am from
Italy I'm a follower a subscriber from
italy and i hope you the best i hope the
best for you and your family your kids
and everyone around you so keep on doing
these videos never stop so thank you so
much Tim for all the awesome value
you're adding and for everybody watching
take two minutes today to say thank you
to somebody who's have an impact on your
life on your business you'll feel great
they'll feel great you'll spread tons of
Awesome karma in the world keep
believing thank you guys so much for
watching if you liked the video you want
to see more you can subscribe to the
channel I'll see you soon
if you want some believe in your inbox
every week to keep you motivated check
out the link below to join my newsletter